hello welcome to the Dropbox API
tutorial in this tutorial we're going to
see a few different methods that are
available to us in the Dropbox API that
allow us to interact with files and
folders and manipulate them my name is
Christian I'll be your instructor for
this course and I'm sure you're
wondering what we're gonna do and what
you'll need to know so let's jump right
in here as far as what you want to know
it's good to know HTML and JavaScript
but it's not necessary really a lot of
these methods were looking at will be
available for other languages such as
Python for example they just might be a
little bit different syntax but the
overarching principles will remain the
same so as long as you're wanting to
learn about the Dropbox API even if you
don't use the JavaScript SDK which we're
going to use I think you'll find this
useful as for what you'll learn we'll go
over getting some files getting the
thumbnails for those files and moving
those files around now I want to mention
again there are many more options
available in the Dropbox API in many
different methods you can use to
manipulate files and folders but these
are the ones we're gonna go over and
hopefully that'll give you a good basis
for how the API generally works
additionally we'll use some array
methods that maybe you've never seen
before or maybe need some clarification
on how they work we'll use some es6
features such as arrow functions and
we'll learn how to use async/await which
is a fairly new way of dealing with
asynchronous data and is perfect for our
use case as for what we're building
specifically well take a look here and
you'll see that we have a file organizer
3000 as i've affectionately named it we
have a path where we can search for
files or folders and we have them listed
out here with thumbnails at the end of
this lesson we'll be able to organize
every file in any given folder using the
path here and once we hit organized
it'll move those files into different
folders based on their date modified so
that's the app we're gonna build let's
jump right in
before we start coding out the app I'd
like to go over the developer
documentation real quick so if you want
to click right here on the slide or just
go to dropbox.com slash developers you
should see something like this it'll
show you a dashboard of sorts and if you
go over to my apps on the left hand side
you should see a blank page because most
likely you don't have any apps yet and
then you can click on create app up at
the top right that'll get an app started
for you now before I go further I should
mention you don't need to do this to
take this course just going to give you
some brief information on how to set up
an app so that when you do set up an app
you can be familiar with it and it'll
help you know how I set up this app so
first it's going to ask you which API
you want to use for this app we're using
the regular Dropbox API if you wanted to
support teams for Dropbox so multiple
people collaborating within Dropbox then
you might select Dropbox business API
but most likely you're gonna go with the
regular API next we need to choose if
we're going to use just one folder for
our app inside the users Dropbox account
or if we need access to the users entire
Dropbox account for this app I went
ahead and chose app folder although in
reality if we were actually building
this app we would probably want to
choose full Dropbox because this app is
essentially going to organize the users
files and that would require access to
their files lastly we want to pick a
name for app if that's taken already
then it'll tell you that and you can
pick a new one once you're done go ahead
and click create app ok great so now
that should take you to a settings
screen and we'll quickly go through
these first we have our status which
will currently be in development when
you're ready you can go ahead and apply
for production so that it can be
reviewed by the Dropbox team currently
you are also only the user that can
access this and if you want to enable
additional users you can click here now
that still has a limit on it since it's
a development app and if you want to
enable more users than you would want to
apply for production here we have the
permission type that we just chose in
step two and we first set up our app
that's app folder we're only one of the
access to one folder in the users
Dropbox account we don't want access to
their entire Dropbox account and then we
have our app folder name now this is by
default going to be this
as our app itself but if you wanted to
change the name of just that folder your
app name would remain the same just a
folder in the Dropbox users account will
change then you can change it here next
we have the app key and secret now in
this tutorial we're not going to use
these but in a real life app you
probably would app keys and secrets are
good for when you need to do
authorization which is actually the next
section here we can choose where we want
to redirect the user once they have been
authorized allow implicit grant I'm not
going to really go into if you hover
over the I when you actually go to the
page you can see a little more detail
you should probably leave it as is if
you're building a client-side app but
you probably are and generate access
token is where you can get your own
token to work with this is something
I've already done and that we'll use in
our app although I should note that the
token I'm using will be expired by the
time you're viewing this so you may want
to go ahead and do this and plug that in
the screen ba or your own code base
wherever in order to actually play with
some files but this is basically gonna
skip the authorization setup and just
give you a quick way to authorize
Dropbox to check out the folders and
files next we have options for what are
called choosers and savers and they look
like this basically just little buttons
that Dropbox is already created for you
so that if you need to do something
simple like get some files or maybe you
just need to save a file to their
account then instead of building an
entire app you may just want to use a
chooser or a saver and if you do decide
to use one of those this is where you
would put your web address so the
Dropbox knows that that host is okay to
use a chooser or saver next we have web
hooks basically it's the idea that once
I do something here I want to trigger an
action there once I do something with
Dropbox I want to trigger an action with
Gmail or something similar
astly if you are done with this app
maybe you don't need any more you can go
ahead and delete it here just be warned
this is an irreversible action so be
careful the next page we have is the
branding page these options are rather
obvious lastly we have the analytics tab
this naturally shows nothing because we
haven't done anything yet but after a
while you should see some stuff here
real quick before we go on to coding our
app I want to mention the JavaScript SDK
documentation you can click on this
thing to go there it looks something
like this basically it's a list of all
the different methods that are available
in this app we're only going to use a
few different methods so it's really not
going to give you a good idea of
everything Dropbox can do
so go to the documentation check out all
the different methods you can use even
if you're not going to use the
JavaScript SDK in your app maybe you're
coding in Python or something else this
will be helpful because all these
methods are the same are very similar to
what you might use in another language
once again you can head over to Dropbox
comm slash developers when you're ready
to set up an account until then let's go
ahead and start this tutorial
let's begin by importing the Dropbox SDK
one thing you need to make sure of is to
surround Dropbox with curly braces
because this is a named import or export
and once we do that we can go ahead and
use it to create a class or rather
instantiate a class and assign it to a
variable we'll call that DB x for
dropbox and here we're just going to say
new and then dropbox with parentheses
and we're gonna pass in an object to
this function we're just creating a
class for us that once again we're
assigning to DB X now that object's
gonna take two properties one is gonna
be an access token and the other is
going to be a fetch library now there
are different fresh libraries you can
use in which case you'd put whatever
fetch library here but if you just want
to use the native window fetch library
and then you can just put fetch that
uses the es6 feature of simply assuming
that the property and the variable are
the same which they are for the access
token you'll want to go ahead and use
your own because by the time you view
this the X is token I'm going to put
right here is not going to be valid any
longer so go ahead and go to dropbox.com
slash developers I'll go ahead and paste
that link up here and set up your
account to get your own token and wants
to do that you can replace the token
here in whatever lesson you want to play
around with if you don't really want to
play around with the code of course you
don't have to do this everything will
still work it's not absolutely necessary
but part of the beauty of scrim vii and
having lessons on here is that you can
play around if the code and you're not
gonna be able to do that unless you
change out this access tokens so I do
encourage doing that but either way
we've imported our Dropbox SDK and we're
now ready to use this DB X variable
so far all we've done is instantiate our
class in order to see what methods are
available on that class you can go to
the documentation here we're just gonna
go ahead and use as our first method
something called files list folder which
will essentially take the folder and
list out the files inside that folder so
this takes a lot of different options on
the object that we pass in but we're
just going to use for now the path now
to specify the route path we actually
pass an empty string not a slash and I
should note the route path here is going
to be the root of our app folder not the
user's Dropbox account and this is
because when I set up my developer app I
chose that option you can set it to the
user's Dropbox account but I set mine to
the app folder so the routes will
actually be the root of the app folder
not the Dropbox account okay now what's
that gonna do for us that's gonna return
a promise and all I want to do for now
let's go ahead and see what we're
getting back let's hit save okay it
worked we got back it looks like an
object with an entries property and that
value of that entries property is an
array of different objects and each
object seems to represent either a
folder or a file so you'll see here this
first one we have is a folder named
other stuff we have another folder here
named 20:18 another folder here name
2019 looks like we've got a bunch of
files in there and you can see that we
have a lot of data on each of these
files so in the next lesson we'll go
ahead and render these to the browser so
that we're looking at it in a pretty way
that's nice to see instead of in the
console but before we move on I need to
know real quick before you go off and
use this new files list folder method
you've learned you need to know this
might not be all the files in the
account or whatever the path is that
we're trying to get them from there
might be more files and there is a way
and we're gonna learn later on how to
use this to get more files it's called
files list folder continue there's a
different method that Dropbox provides
to us so I just need to make that note
real quick learn how to get more files
later on
now we're just learning how to get that
first response however many files
Dropbox is willing to give us and in the
next lesson once again we'll learn how
to render those files to the browser
as it is now our application only logs
the result that we're getting back from
Dropbox that's fun and all but let's see
if we can render things to the browser I
know this tutorial is more about Dropbox
but I thought I might be useful to see
how we're making things happen in the
Dom first of all we need to declare an
element to interact with here I'm
declaring a variable called vilest LM
for element and using document query
selector to select an element with the
class of Jas file list I like to put J s
at the beginning of my class names just
to know that I'm dealing with JavaScript
so I don't accidentally mess with them
when I'm just dealing with HTML or CSS
I'm going to go ahead and do a little
refactoring here to set up our app what
I've just done is declare a state
variable that will hold our state right
now it's just one files property which
is an empty array I've moved our call to
the files list folder endpoint into an
init function which we can call at the
end after declaring our other functions
I've declared an update files function
which will take some files and update
the state accordingly so that we keep
all our old files that were in state as
well as updated with the new ones and
inside that we're also calling our
render files function which will fill in
now inside render files we'll first need
to get our element so that we can place
some HTML in there now there are two
things I want to do with the files here
first I want to sort them then I want to
map over them and for every one of them
create an li element so that we can see
the list let's sort alphabetically and
let's go ahead and put the folders on
top okay real quick I'll go over what
we're doing here on this line we're
comparing the dot tag property of each
item if you recall what we log to the
console every item in the array is going
to have a dot tag property that is
either a folder or file what we're
basically saying here is are either one
of these items a folder if so we're
gonna need to prioritize the folder next
we're checking are they the same if
they're both folders or if
both files we don't need to do anything
with them except for organize them
alphabetically which we do here but if
one of them is folder and one of them is
a file we're going to check which one is
a folder if it's the first one we return
negative one to say that it should come
first and if it's the second one we
return positive one to say that should
come second in this way we're sorting
all our folders on top and resorting
everything alphabetically next we turn
to our dot map method we're just going
to loop through every item in the array
and return an array the map method of an
array accepts a function the first
argument is each item in that array in
our case a file or folder in fact let's
go ahead and check what type this is
will say Kronk's type equals file and
then if you'll recall the dot pag
property is what stores whether it's a
file or a folder then we just want to
return our actual HTML I'm gonna go
ahead and use back ticks to create a
template literal inside this template
literal whatever I put will be what's
returned it will take it literally hence
the name so let's return an element and
what we want to see ultimately in the
browser is the name of the file if we
were to look at our console again and
see what is being returned from Dropbox
we'll see that there's a dot main
property on every file so we'll put that
in there I also want to go ahead and do
some styling real quick I've already
declared a class of dbx list item for
each individual item in the list and
then I also want to put the type that we
just declared above so we know if it's a
file or folder okay now before that's
actually gonna do anything we do need to
replace our console dot log up here so
that instead of logging in we're
actually calling all this logic and to
do that we will call update files with
the files that we get back from Dropbox
once again if you were to look at that
console that we logged earlier in the
last lesson you'll see that there's a
dot entries property on that object
which holds the array of files so now we
have our init function calling our
update files function which calls our
render files function which will
ultimately render something to the Dom
however if we were to call this right
now
we would see a bunch of commas in
between every Ally element let me go
ahead and hit save to show you what I
mean as you can see we've successfully
logged the items of the array however we
are seeing commas in between every item
and that's simply because we're not
returning a string here to our dot
innerhtml we're returning an array we
don't really want to do that we want to
return a string so let's take this array
let's call the dot join method which
will join every element in the array
into one string and inside we can pass
what kind of separator we want to use in
our case we don't want a separator we
just want one long string so we'll pass
an empty string where it's save again
and now voila we can see all of our
items we can see that our folder is up
on top other stuff and we can see that
they are ordered alphabetically now
that's not really easy to tell that this
is a folder so in the next lesson we'll
go ahead and add some thumbnails
right now our app is working and we're
displaying our files but it doesn't look
great yet what we'd like to do in this
lesson is go ahead and add some
thumbnails now this lessons going to
concentrate on simply rendering those
thumbnails and the next lesson we'll see
how we can get the actual thumbnails for
each file from Dropbox what we want to
do here ultimately is in our render
function while we're mapping over each
file is check if that file has a
thumbnail property and if so use it and
if not go ahead and use a default now
the first thing to keep in mind here is
that folders do not have thumbnails so
essentially if our first check is going
to say are we dealing with file and if
we are dealing with a file then we can
go ahead and use the thumbnail if not
we'll just use a default folder
thumbnail let's start by declaring a
thumbnail variable first we have our
check to see if it's a file if it is we
want to go ahead and use the thumbnail
property on the file in other words the
actual thumbnail and if not we want to
go ahead and use a default thumbnail
we're gonna go ahead and check this with
a ternary expression in case you're not
familiar with ternary expressions they
essentially take the form of if
something and if that's true do
something and if it's not do something
else
hey so let's go ahead and write that out
what are we going to test well first of
all we need to assign something to our
thumbnail variable and here's where our
ternary expression starts we're gonna go
ahead and check if there is a thumbnail
property on our file if there is then
we're going to go ahead and use that
thumbnail and if not we'll use a default
okay now the thumbnail being returned by
Dropbox is going to be a base64 image
essentially that's just one big long
string that's a representation of an
image instead of an actual file it's a
string that represents an image how do
we use that in HTML well it looks
something like this but an important
part I suppose here is in the beginning
we're gonna start with data call an
image and then our type of image and
then base64 comma and then our base 64
string this big long string is just a
default file from the
in case we don't have a thumbnail
available on our file but if we do we
want to go ahead and use that thumbnail
okay so you'll see we're essentially
starting with the same thing except this
file is going to be a JPEG that is the
default of the file format from Dropbox
then we're using a template literal with
an inserted variable to insert our
base64 string so this is going to be
whatever base64 string Dropbox provides
just review one more time we're
assigning our thumbnail variable to
either the actual thumbnail if it exists
or a default thumbnail if it does not
for our folders once again folders don't
have thumbnails so we can simply use the
default okay once again that's just a
big long string it's a folder thumbnail
as we'll see in just a moment the last
thing we need to do is actually insert
the thumbnail in our HTML so we're going
to go ahead and use an image tag here
I'm gonna put a class on the image
because I've already set this up in my
CSS just to make it look nice and then
of course we need to declare our source
for our image tag it's going to be
America which is the variable we have
declared and assigned based on whether
or not there is one and whether or not
it's a file or a folder okay
let's save and see what happens there we
go we've got our thumbnails as you can
see we have a folder here and the rest
of them are files now obviously these
are default thumbnails and in the next
lesson we'll learn how we can get the
actual thumbnails from Dropbox
in the last lesson we learned how to
render thumbnails with our files in this
lesson we'll go ahead and learn how to
get the actual thumbnails from Dropbox
if you look at the documentation which
I've linked at the top here you'll find
there is a method available to us called
files get thumbnail batch and that
function takes an argument which is an
object that has an entries property
which is an array of objects each object
having a path and an optional size this
is the basic format for the request
we'll be making
okay so we're getting an array of files
and we want to turn that into an array
of paths so let's go ahead and do that
now we'll say cons paths equals what we
need to do to our array first well first
this builds around all the folders
because folders don't have some names
here we're using the filter method on an
array and that takes a function the
first argument of which is the item in
the array we're working on and it simply
returns true or false if it returns true
we keep that item returns false we get
rid of it in this case we're checking to
see if the dot tag property is equal to
file because if it is it's file and we
want to keep it if it's not we don't
want to keep it now that we've filtered
our array so that we only have files and
no folders we can go ahead and map over
every item and what we'll ultimately
want to return for every item is this
object down here okay so we need to
return that item but how do we do that
instead of just typing curly braces we
can actually surround those curly braces
in parentheses to return a literal
object all right so what is our path
well that's actually available on the
file itself as path lower if you'll
recall we originally started this app by
making a call to files list holder which
gave us a list of folders and files each
of which had lots of information and one
of those pieces of information is passed
lower for the size you'll have to go
ahead and look at the documentation to
see what sizes are available
for our uses we want to go ahead and use
32 by 32 okay
so instead of this array here we will
pass the pass away we just created and
that will return a promise so let's go
ahead and see what we get back simply by
logging into the console before we can
do that however there are a couple
things we need to do first off if we
look at our documentation will find that
this thumbnail batch call actually has a
limit on it
so we can't get more than 25 at a time
turns out this files this folder call
also has an option for a limit so this
would be a good place to remedy back
let's go ahead and put a limit of 20 for
our demo purposes and then of course we
need to call our new function somewhere
let's go ahead and call it in the update
files function and make sure to pass in
the files great okay so when we
initialize our app we are making a call
to files this folder to get the files
and folders then we're calling update
files and then we are calling get
thumbnails let's go ahead and save to
see what happens all right looks like we
got a success if we look at the console
you'll see there's a lot of information
there but essentially we're just getting
an object with an entries property and
an array of files and folders well in
this case actually just an array of
files alright so now that we have our
response back from Dropbox we are ready
to start working with it and assign our
thumbnails to our files essentially what
we want to do is just create a thumbnail
property on each file object that holds
the thumbnail data now this next part
gets a little bit complicated so I'm
just gonna go ahead and paste it out and
then we can walk through a step by step
first of all we're gonna make a copy of
our current state that files array we do
that very easily with the es6 spread
operator that's those three dots here at
the beginning that's essentially telling
JavaScript to spread the items of the
array into this a new this new array so
we do that and we call our new variable
new to save files next we want to loop
through the res entry
arrey that we got back from dropbox at
res dot entries array is just going to
be an array of objects each object has a
lot of information on it but one of the
properties on the object is thumbnail
and that's the one we're interested in
we want to get the thumbnail of that
object so we're gonna loop through each
item in the array and in order to know
which item we need to update the
thumbnail of we first need to figure out
where it is in the array so we're
declaring here a variable called indexed
updates that's going to figure out okay
what item in our new state files array
remember that's just a copy of our
current state which item do we need to
put a thumbnail on and the way we figure
that out is using a method called find
index this is a method available on the
array prototype so any array you work
with its gonna have this find index
method and it's similar to the dot
filter method that we use earlier in
that it's ultimately going to return
either true or false
and what we're testing here is just see
if the path is the same so if the path
is the same it's the same file right and
if it's the same file that's the one we
want to update so we pass an argument to
the item we're gonna be working on and
we just test to see if the path is the
same and if it is that's the index that
we want to use so we plug that index in
here and we say in our new site files
array find this index and add the dot
thumbnail property to it and make it
equal to whatever the thumbnail was that
Dropbox returned for that file and once
we do all that for every single item in
the array we can finally assign state
dot files to our new array of files and
the only difference here is this array
has thumbnails
that's the only difference between these
two rates so we've added our thumbnails
to our items in our array and finally we
render them to the screen but sit save
and see what happens
alright looks like everything is working
we've got our actual thumbnails next to
each item everything seems to be working
fine you'll notice that at the top here
we have a folder and that does not have
a thumbnail which is normal but every
other file does so everything was
successful and we're ready to move on
so far we've introduced two API calls
into our app the first was files this
folder in the second files get thumbnail
badge
both of these have returned promises
using dot then which make working with
asynchronous data a little easier
however we're going to need to make some
more calls in the future and we'd like
to move away from promises into a
feature in es7 called async await the
way async await works is simply we
declare async before our function so
instead of just writing out the function
put the async keyword right before it
now inside of that function we can use
the await keyword let's go ahead and
call our variable of Redd's just like
before this time we'll put a weight
before our function call so comrades
equals a weight whatever our
asynchronous call is long as that
returns a promise this should work and
we can get rid of our been call and
instead act like this is just a regular
variable essentially if you picture this
function being a synchronous function
we're working with asynchronous data the
same way it's as if we were saying Const
res equals 1 plus 2 and then using it
just like we normally would only this
function is asynchronous and by using
async await we are telling JavaScript to
wait until this function is complete
before moving on to the update files
call and then using this variable let's
go ahead and do the same thing with our
get thumbnails function again well
declare the async keyword before the
function and we will simplify here by
assigning our data to a res variable
once again we can get rid of the dot
then call and we can go ahead and use
all the stuff we've done earlier in
pretty much the same format only now
it's a lot cleaner it just looks like
we're dealing with synchronous data
we're assigning a variable Reds to
whatever data we get back here and as
long as we include the await keyword
before our asynchronous
we should be good let's go ahead and
save and see if this still works looks
like everything still works so that's
how you use async/await
to simplify your code and make working
with asynchronous data a little bit more
manageable we'll go ahead and continue
to use async await in future lessons
we just learned how to render thumbnails
after getting them from Dropbox in order
to get those thumbnails we had to limit
our first call to get files to only 25
at the very most
and we chose 20 however there are more
than 20 files in our folder in this
folder that we're using for our demo
that are actually 37 files so what do we
do if we want our thumbnails but we
still want to get all the files while
Dropbox has a way to do this for the
sake of demo purposes let's go ahead and
change this limit to 5 as you can see
here we're only getting 5 files one of
them is a folder to show how we can
resolve this I'm going to take a look at
an online tool that Dropbox provides and
I linked it right here they call it the
API Explorer if you go ahead and open up
that link you might see something like
this there are a bunch of methods listed
on the left-hand side that you don't see
in the slide here but one of those
methods is list folder and you may
recognize that name because we're using
the JavaScript SDK equivalent right here
files list folder now online if you look
at the tool you'll be able to see the
different options that are available and
you can enter a path and you can enter a
limit for example and then you can go
ahead and submit that call to see what
happens if you do that you might see a
response that looks something like this
this should look somewhat familiar to us
we have our entries property which is an
array of files however there are two
things we haven't looked at yet and
that's these last two properties the
cursor and has more the cursor is
essentially a very long string that
keeps track of where we are in the
process or in the folder it's sort of
like a you were here last time you made
this call pointer and the has more
property tells us are there more files
to get in this case it looks like there
are so we can use the has more property
to tell if we have more files to get and
we can use the cursor to actually get
those files and we would do that with
another method that's similar to the one
we already used if we look at the API
Explorer it will be under list folder
slash continue now the JavaScript SDK
name will be a little bit different
but we'll go ahead and look at this for
now if you look at the online tool
you'll be able to enter the cursor right
here in a box and submit a call that
will show you another object similar to
what we've already seen we have an
entries property which is an array of
files and you can do this over and over
again until finally at the very end once
there are no more files you'll see has
more equal to false in other words for
every response we get from Dropbox we
want to check the has more property and
if it's true use the cursor to get some
more files and then repeat that process
until eventually has more will be false
and that's what we'll learn how to do in
our next lesson
our app is going to start by calling
this an NIT function inside of that
function we are getting some files and
folders from Dropbox reliving them to
only 20 for the sake of getting
thumbnails and then we are rendering
them after we make this call though we
won't check if there are more files so
let's check that has more property that
we discussed in the last lesson and if
it's true we will call a function called
get more files which we haven't set up
yet but let's just type it out for now
and into that function we'll need to
pass the cursor so it can use that to
get more files and in this case since
we'd like something to happen with those
files right away
we'll also passed a callback so this is
going to be a callback function here
that's gonna receive more files from our
get more files function and what I'm
going to do with those files well we
wanna do the same thing we did with our
first set of files
don't call update files and remember
that the entries property is where those
files are stored once again we're gonna
call it get more files function that we
still need to create we're going to pass
in the cursor and we're also gonna pass
in a callback function so that when more
files are retrieved those files can be
passed into this function and we can
update files okay now when we're doing
this I'd like to show a loading message
to the user so they know something's
happening let's go ahead and store that
in a variable here now that we have that
variable we can simply hide or show that
elements whenever we're loading or not
loading okay so we're showing our
loading message we're running our get
more files function we're hiding our
loading message and in case we don't
actually have any more files we'll skip
that block all together and we'll just
make sure our loading message is hidden
now this get more files function is
obviously going to be asynchronous so we
need to make sure to put a weight here
and that keyword will work because this
omit function is asynchronous if we
didn't have this async keyword here not
a weight keyword and this away keyword
would not work but they do so after I
get more files functions complete then
we can continue with our code now we get
to create our get more files function
okay the first thing we need to do is
figure out what Dropbox method
there is for us to call if we look at
the documentation we'll find that there
is a method very similar to files this
folder called files list folder continue
and that method is going to take an
object with a cursor property which is
going to be the heat cursor using object
good structuring we can actually shorten
this to just say cursor because it is
assumed when you write it like this that
the property name and the variable that
is the value will be the same which they
are for getting our cursor value here
and so this is just a shorthand way of
saying cursor is equal to cursor after
we do that and keep in mind that's
asynchronous so we'll need to make sure
this is in a synchronous function and
we'll check if there was a callback
provided to this function and if so call
it with our response now as it is right
now we are only checking for more files
one time but obviously we need to do
that until there are no more files to
get so once again we'll check that has
more property and if there are more
files to get we'll just use recursion to
call this same file again this time
we'll pass in the cursor we got from our
second call and we'll pass in the same
callback function okay so get more files
we'll run it we'll check if there are
more files using the cursor it will make
a callback and if there are more files
still even after that call that we just
made then it will call this same
function yet again and it will keep
doing that until has more is false in
which case it will skip this call right
here one more thing we need to remember
is this awaked keyword it's easy to
forget but do recall this get more files
function is asynchronous so our files as
folder continue functions asynchronous
and our get more files function as
asynchronous so they both need this
await keyword okay let's save and see
what happens you may have noticed that
the first response was updated shortly
after with some new files and if you
scroll down you'll see we have a lot
more than 20 right now
looks like is working so we're making
our initial call to get some files we're
updating our browser then we're checking
if there are more files if
so we'll show a loading message and
we'll wait for a get more files function
which will get more files call the
callback and once again check if there
are still more files and if so repeat
this loop until eventually there are no
more files at which point this code will
continue because of our await keyword
and hide the loading message
we've done some pretty cool things in
our app already however one thing that
would be nice is if we weren't
restricted to just the route path all
the time let's go ahead and build that
out now
if we look at our app currently you'll
see I've made some changes with the CSS
and HTML but the important thing for
this lesson is this folder path input up
here ideally we'd like to let the user
enter some sort of path in here and go
to it in our app right now we only have
one folder other stuff so it'd be nice
if the user could say hey I want to go
to other stuff and get entered or hit
button and go to the path right now it's
not working it's just refreshing the
page so let's go ahead and build out
that logic first off we'll need to
declare a couple new variables to
reference some HTML elements and get the
data from that form so we've declared
one element for the form and one element
for the input why do we need both well
for the form we want to use that to
listen to the submit event that's how
we'll know when the user has actually
changed anything about the path so we'll
add an event listener and listen for
that submit event which will give us an
event I've labeled that as EE here and
the first thing we need to do is prevent
the default behavior of forms because
that will refresh the page and we don't
want that next we need to get the value
for the inputs remember that is at route
path input that's declared up here and
we can get the value simply by saying
that value however in Dropbox the route
path is expressed with an empty string
and not a slash which a lot of people
are used to so I do real quick want to
do a check and see if they entered it
equal to a slash if so let's go ahead
and use an empty string if not we can go
ahead and use that value also people
sometimes make mistakes with
capitalization and such so let's turn
this into a lowercase string that way
we're always dealing with lowercase now
we're not actually doing anything with
this variable yet so let's think about
what we might need to do it would be
nice if this root path was available
throughout our app we
to use it elsewhere so let's actually go
ahead and put that on spate it might
change over time so that seems like a
good place to put it okay so now we are
assigning the root path property of the
state object to whatever the root path
is that the user enters when they submit
the form what else do we need to do well
we don't want to show the folders and
files from the old path so let's go
ahead and clear those out also there is
one quick thing I want to do with the
HTML all I'm doing here is referencing
that loading element that you see
sometimes when the app first starts and
I'm removing the hidden class to show
the user that it is loading and well if
you think about it we're basically
starting over in our app when we first
bought the app it's loading files and
then what's downloading that loading
message is hidden and we can start using
it we want to do the same thing here
every time the user changes the path so
let's just go ahead and call our init
function right now that will basically
start our app over it we'll get this
files this folder called and it will
search for whatever the path is except
we don't want an empty string here we
want whatever our root path is that the
user entered okay so any time the user
submits that root path field it will get
the value it will store it on our state
it will show a hidden message and it
will reinitialize our app oh I just
realized I forgot to put parentheses
after our two lowercase method
sorry about that now let's go ahead and
save and see what happens okay we only
have one folder here other stuff so I
guess that's the folder we're gonna be
testing here we go
and it works I can look in my Dropbox
account and confirm this is indeed the
contents of the other stuff folder so
everything is working as it should in
the next lesson we'll learn how to make
this organize button work to magically
move our files into their respective
folders
at last we reach the main function of
our app the ability to organize our
files into folders based on the date
modified let's get started first we'll
need to get a reference to the button
element we'll go ahead and call it
organized button then we need to listen
for a click on that button
since organizing our files will be
asynchronous let's show some sort of
message to our user to indicate that
something's happening
first we'll disable the button and then
after we disable the button let's show a
message then we'll go ahead and carry
out our organize operation that is
asynchronous so we'll need to make sure
this is an asynchronous function and
we'll need to wait for that to complete
once it completes we can rename our
button and in order to restore the
previous texts we'll need to grab that
first and that we have a variable to
reference the text before it was clicked
we can restore that okay now we're ready
to create our move file sedated folders
function
first off let's establish which Dropbox
method we need to use in order to move
files around for this function we will
use files moved batch v2 they have a
version two of this function that's what
we'll use here that takes an object as
an argument with a you guessed it
entries property and that entries
property is an array of objects each
object having a from path and a to path
so we're removing it from and where are
we moving it to now of course we want
hard-code this array we will generate it
so let's call that array entry so that
we can simplify it using object b
structuring and let's create that
entries array up here that will be based
on our state that files array so we're
taking whatever files are in our state
currently and we're gonna perform two
operations on them first of all we're
gonna filter out the folders just like
we did with our get thumbnails method
then we're gonna map over every file and
what we ultimately want to return is an
object with a from path and a to path
now the from path is going to be pretty
simple
that's just file dot path the lower
that's available on the metadata we got
from our very first drop box called the
to path is what we'll need to build
based on the date now the file does have
a property on it called client modified
and that will tell us the date that is
last modified so that's already taken
care of for us just so you know there
also is a server modified property but
for this case we will use client
modified and it's put in such a format
that we can actually use it with the
JavaScript date constructor so we will
do that in order to have this bait
variable
something that will be able to work with
in order to get the year and the month
and whatever other information we need
from this date okay so essentially what
we're gonna use to build our path is a
template literal with four different
variables we have our route then our
year then our month and then the file me
so for the route that's found on our
state object so state that route path
our year is going to come from that date
variable we just created and you can get
that by
by being in here to get full year or
month is gonna be a little bit weirder
than a year it's gonna be get UTC months
and also the month number is one behind
what you might think it would be so Dan
you area is actually zero so we add one
to whatever the month says it is in
order to make it more reasonable and
then finally we have a file name alright
that's all for this lesson in the next
lesson we're gonna finish building our
move files function and we're actually
going to see our app do its magic
in the previous lesson we set up this
entries array and we pass it into the
property of entries on our object which
we passed into files move batch b2 from
Dropbox which is going to move our files
around now we need to handle whatever
Dropbox does so what is it going to do
and what's it going to return to us well
it could return one of two things
it may be an object saying that the job
is done which will say success or it may
be an object with an asynchronous job ID
now if we get back an asynchronous job
ID then we know that's still working so
here I am just pulling out that property
from our response object and if that
property exists whatever's inside of
this if block will run and so what do we
need to do in here while we need to
check on that job now how do we do that
Dropbox actually provides a similar
method to us and that method is called
files move batch check v2 and in that
method we pass in an object with our
asynchronous job ID okay so we'll want
to make sure that we're waiting for this
to complete and you'll notice I use the
left keyword there because we're going
to reassign that res variable and we're
gonna do that right here because we want
to reassign it to a new value when we
check on the current status but we don't
want to do that one time we actually
need to keep doing that until we get a
response saying that that job is done so
how do we do that well we're gonna use
set up a loop here we've set up a
do-while loop with a do-while loop the
logic inside the brackets will run at
least one time regardless of our logic
here inside of the parentheses that's
what we want we need to make sure if
we're getting an asynchronous job ID
back from our response that we're
checking or following up on that at
least one time then it will keep doing
that as long as this logic inside our
Wow parenthesis is true and here we're
simply checking the Tag property of our
response to see if it's still in
progress as long as that dock tag
property is in progress our job is still
working so we need to keep checking so
we will loop over this continually until
eventually that dot I property is some
else maybe success maybe failure either
way we know the job is finally done now
that's it who are our move files
function but once that's all done we
want to change the UI a bit so let's go
back up to our button here we are
waiting for our function to be done and
after it's done
we are re-enabling our button and we are
showing the original message of our
button but we also need to reinitialize
our state just like we did with our root
path form so when someone changes the
path we need to clear out the current
state of files show the new files the
new path and we need to show that
loading message while we're doing that
and then we need to reinitialize our
whole app so we want to do the exact
same logic and because of that I'm going
to refactor here a little bit ok all
I've done here is move that logic into
its own function called reset and we're
calling that same function with our root
path form and our organized button ok so
that's pretty much everything we need to
do let's save and see what happens all
right the moment of truth here we go now
as you can see we're getting responses
back from Dropbox this is our loop
running it is logging out whatever
response we get and you'll see that dodd
tag property is still in progress so
that loop needs to keep running and our
button is disabled and it says it's
working so we are waiting for this job
to complete and there we go you can see
we have a dot tag property with complete
and if you look at our file structure
well there are no files we just have
folders now we have a 20-18 folder and a
20-19 folder we still have our other
stuff folder so that has a move which is
good let's go ahead and check out the
contents of these new folders 2018 ok
that has a 12 folder so that's December
let's go into that and see what we have
and there we go here are our files looks
like all the files moved successfully
into our folder and we've set it up so
that there's also a 20-19 folder with
january so it looks like our files were
spanning across two different months and
they've all been moved successfully
our app
officialy works awesome now there is one
thing I want to mention real quick and
that is error handling it's not
something we've really done in any of
our methods thus far but it's definitely
advised in the real world and with
async/await it's actually not too hard
you simply surround your code with a
try-catch block so we're gonna try
whatever is in these brackets and if it
is successful then great it just carries
on and does this thing otherwise if
there's any kind of error it can go
ahead and pass that error into a catch
block and we can do whatever we want
here we could log into the console or we
could show something to the user the
latter would be preferable because we
want the user to know something went
wrong and that's the whole purpose of
error handling so that we can actually
do something with these errors and it
could be a better user experience so
when you build your own app it's
definitely advisable to do some kind of
error handling and once again you can
wrap stuff in a try-catch block to at
least form the basic foundation of error
handling so that's just a quick preview
into how you might handle some errors
just in case something goes wrong with
Dropbox so there's a network failure or
whatever it may be and with that we're
just gonna leave our app as is it's
basically complete of course you can add
more features you're definitely
encouraged to do so but for the sake of
our demo what you see is officially our
app
congratulations you've made it to the
end of the Dropbox API course thanks so
much for taking the time to look at this
I hope it was inspiring just to recap
what we've learned so far we learned how
to get files and display those in the
browser we learned how to get thumbnails
for those files and display those as
well and we learned how to move files
around in the actual Dropbox account as
for the JavaScript side of things we
learned some array methods such as
sorting and filtering we saw some es6
features being used like arrow functions
and we learned async/await which is a
great way to deal with asynchronous data
in general especially when you're
working with API is like this one once
again my name is Christian it was a lot
of fun putting this course together I
hope that you will head over to Dropbox
comm slash developers and set up your
own amp and then go and look at the
documentation to find some more methods
that you can use and some more cool
things that you can do with Dropbox
that's the end of our Dropbox course I
just want to challenge you one more time
go ahead build something cool and share
it with the world